oh i'm ready for the draft and you have
the question for me we are drafting the
wild card quarterbacks
in whom we trust the most who's in the
trust rate all right so this saturday
buffalo will host its first playoff game
since 1995.
what two teams have a longer drought
of not hosting a playoff game that's a
tough one
i don't know this one either i'm going
to help you out i think here
well hmm wow i'm going to say detroit
lions
is that one of them i gotta think it is
is that wall wall
yes it is yes okay that's one i would
say
that the cleveland browns would be the
other one you would be correct way to go
okay
all right way to go way to go
yes man anytime and i'm telling you
no matter how many times we do this when
the red light's on and the clock is
ticking
and you have this broad canvas of things
to choose from
it's easy to panic uh one guy who won't
be panicking
ever in a playoff game is a guy who's
played more than two full seasons
of playoff games in his career tom brady
is the quarterback that i trust the most
in this round this is child's play for
him he's not going to freak out
especially against washington so he's
the guy i trust the most
i don't know i i patrick mahomes
probably a little bit more if we're
doing the full playoffs but at least for
the 12 teams
that are playing this weekend tom brady
by far
is my number one yeah i i think that's
the number one pick there's no doubt
about that i i feel like i mean
nerves or like anything like that are
gonna have nothing to do with don
brady's play
you said it right this is gonna be
nothing this is just like pre-game
warm-ups to him
um the only way i could see him being
and getting in trouble in this game or
just being too loose maybe
you know being too aggressive hey we're
hot i'm gonna throw rifles and fireballs
all over the field and
that becomes you know a tip pass
interception that kind of stuff so we'll
see
um but i'm with you brady is clearly
number one i think at number two
you know russell wilson's got to be my
next pick
for this weekend again russell wilson's
played in two super bowls he's played a
lot of playoff
football he understands pressure you
know whether it's
having to play through the defense or
the run game or having to do it all
himself
he can do it either way and russell
wilson is still phenomenal quarterback
yeah he's still not going to get an mvp
vote this year
but he's still one of the best the game
has to offer
russell was my number three at my number
two
was your boy blue blue i am surprised
just because i put him ahead of russ
because because he's on fire right now
we have seen
him become he has basically forced his
way into the conversation of best
quarterback in the nfl he's done it one
game at a time
it's happening in front of our eyes
we're still kind of
influenced by the leftover
sense that he's got 50 accuracy
and he's not going to be very good and
the stuff that you hear people say
whenever he has an off day
to justify their evaluation that was
wrong from three years ago
meanwhile what's happening right in
front of us is he is awesome
since the loss to the cardinals via the
hail murray this team has
changed he has changed and they keep
going next level next level next level
so
uh although the colts i don't think are
an ideal match up because
they're gonna run the ball apparently
and 253 yards from jonathan taylor who's
supposed to be hitting the rookie wall
that's not that's not good news for the
bills and and we're almost at the point
now
with the buffalo offense where it's keep
josh allen on the sideline drinking
gatorade
so slow the game down take the full 40
seconds you got a smart guy like philip
rivers who knows how to manage
the clock to perfection but still i have
i have full faith in josh allen
first home game for the bills in the
postseason since december of 1996 with
fans there
first game this year with fans yeah he's
going to be on fire
i i don't doubt any of that i mean it's
it's a great
he would have been my next pick i gave
russell the slight advantage just
through experience
i don't think russell's playing at a
high level as josh allen right now
certainly you know i mean you you're
you're
you're you think he's second in mvp
voting probably right behind aaron
rodgers and you think it's pretty close
and i'm with you i agree there so i'm
excited to see what he does this weekend
nonetheless
all right my next one i'm going with
ryan tannehill
uh he's gonna he's my next quarterback
yeah i try you know listen i know big
ben and drew brees
are there on the board and all that i
sorry i don't trust them
not to the way i trust ryan tannehill
first off i saw him play good playoff
football last year
and you can trust him too to take care
of the football like he did against the
patriots
or did against the ravens and won those
football games even though it wasn't
like
easy throwing the ball and it wasn't a
pretty game or sexy on the offensive
side of the ball so
i trust tannehill one because he doesn't
turn the ball over two
he is arguably the most accurate or
one of the most accurate deep ball
throwers in the game they got that run
game that goes with it so he knows he
doesn't have to force the ball
and quite honestly he's plays at an
extremely high level i trust him a lot
i i'm surprised i'm going to pick lamar
jackson with my final whoa
but i am because even though he's on two
in the playoffs
he's in a different mindset now and the
way that this team has developed and
matured
and they are overpowering opponents now
i don't think he's going to be flustered
i don't think he's going to be phased i
don't think he's going to be freaked out
i think he's just going to go take care
of business this weekend
even though they're on the road they're
favorites to beat the titans and if they
run the ball like they've been running
the ball lately they will
yeah i i hear you there i i think that's
very
fair and in the conversation if we're
going to evaluate it for this year and
everything we've seen
and like the way they're playing right
now yeah lamar is
he's i was sitting there going wait what
am i going to do with my last pick am i
going to pick lamar
big ben or drew brees i'm not sure there
now i'm down to big ben and drew brees
and i'm not sure where i am here on that
either
you know baker's in that conversation
for me too i don't trust philip rivers
i'm
sorry and big ben and drew have not
exactly blown us away with playoff
performances
i think i'll go with drew brees here
even though i don't feel terribly
comfortable with it but he does have the
run game the top offensive line
one of the best defenses in football and
i'm gonna play
the fact of their playoff struggles and
everything like that
he's gonna play good here down the
playoffs and we're not talking about the
saints enough
i have a feeling they're enjoying going
under the radar
was your number 12 john wolford or
mitchell trubisky uh it was wolford
it was wolford yes uh he was he was 12.
when you combine wolford with sean mcvay
i know it's close you're right you're
right you're there's that aspect of it
you know there's no doubt but trubisky
the way he's played so much so well
lately i've gotta give him the edge
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports